una nueva jornada de protestas los
sindicatos propusieron al gobierno
recurrir a la mediación para resolver el
conflicto pero el plan fracasó lo que
enfureció a los franceses que volvieron
a salir a las calles de todo el país
para participar en la décima jornada de
huelga contra la reforma del sistema de
pensiones en burdeos los manifestantes
no muestran intenciones de dar marcha
atrás Hay que preguntar quién no quiere
diálogo todo el mundo cree que hace
falta calma entonces hay que buscar una
salida presentamos una propuesta de
solución pero parece que el gobierno aún
no está listo la inconformidad también
se apoderó de la ciudad de Hans donde
adultos mayores y jóvenes se sumaron por
décima vez a la ola de protestas la
misma escena en Marsella desde las ocho
de la mañana las principales carreteras
quedaron cortadas en ambos sentidos
especialmente las cercanas al antiguo
puerto de la ciudad en Ans lo
manifestantes recrearon una repetición
de los hechos que Francia presenció en
mayo de 1968 en la ciudad de Niza
exhibieron un muñeco que la imagen del
presidente francés como una forma de
denunciar lo que llamaron decisiones
dictatoriales Aunque no me afecta
directamente porque ya soy jubilado en
un mundo donde todos piensan de forma
egoísta es bueno expresar solidaridad el
país se ha paralizado diez veces y los
estallidos al cabo de cada jornada que
incluyen enfrentamientos con la policía
amenazan la seguridad por ello el
ministro del interior decidió esta vez
desplegar una fuerza récord que asciende
a 13.000 efectivos en todo el país
incluidos 5500 en la capital